[Music]
I stay up too late
are you getting this music
[Music]
I never miss a Beat
baby
[Music]
oh aren't they great what are you
kidding me it's like watching Jello
dancing around like you could do any
better pipsqueak
you want to see something great I'll
show you
[Music]
oh
and Rosita
[Applause]
[Music]
all right piggy power
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
boy can you hear me I said turn it
[Music]
up
I'm still standing yeah yeah
I'm still standing
you made out
just the circles
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll still standing
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
what's with the face you were great they
loved you
yeah thanks Rosia
[Music]
[Applause]
dude
you are all trespassing a private
property and you will leave right now
all of you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I am calling the police
I can't do anything
[Music]
seriously she's not even that good
yeah yeah totally
good
Ness
[Music]
I can find
when you set it up
[Music]
I
you guys okay
[Applause]
[Music]
cause you're a sky Cause You're A Sky
Full of Stars
I'm Gonna Give You My Heart
cause your Sky Cause You're A Sky Full
of Stars
cause you light up the past that's my
boy
[Music]
I don't care I don't
care if you do
[Music]
cause in the sky goes in the sky full of
stars I think I saw you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
give me that I'm your costume now wait
what take it off now
and we'll be at the theater soon sir I
don't want to be there soon I want to be
there now yeah we want to be there now
yes sir
[Music]
I think I saw you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
mission report my search takes me to the
second planet the planet of Joy all
right here we go Porsha time to show the
world what you're really made of
[Music]
loud dialogue
right now
hey who the heck are you where's my
security where's
[Music]
Could Have Been Me
ant it could have been me
[Music]
ant
don't you make me come out there
[Music]
[Applause]
you traitor that's it I'm coming out
there
Crowley put some cushions and snacks
down there so you should be comfortable
to the shows
[Music]
[Applause]
it could have been me
[Music]
[Applause]
I got you now your low-life little loser
no sir
I'm not a loser
we did what we came here to do and there
is nothing you can do or say to change
that
yeah
all I can do whatever I want
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
hello baby
[Music]
[Applause]